just a little bit of background I was a
serial entrepreneur for 20-some odd
years in the valley came out of 78 I
retired in the internet bubble not
because I was a genius but because I
went to go home so I took the money off
the table and retired in 99 and actually
had some time to reflect on successes
and failures over the last after it was
eight startups one of the things I did
taking some time off is I thought I'm
gonna write my memoirs great successful
entrepreneur great executive all I was
so proud of myself and I started typing
got 80 pages into it my wife and
daughter were out skiing of snow in
Tahoe watching the snow come down pipe
that cockeyed story short very I was
impressed
oh look at this and when I was done 80
pages I looked at it and said I'd have
to pay my wife and kids to read this and
that was the entire total available
market probably the book but when I read
actually then with another I of thanks
Steve for chuckling over this but I I
realized I accomplished two things one
is just emotionally for retirement it
really was a catharsis about you know
purging all of 20-some odd years of war
stories realizing that I probably could
have been been indicted for most of this
stuff in public companies at least today
but to is most importantly in relevant
to today's discussion was I realized
there were some patterns that were just
coming up again and again not only in
company that I had done an 8 was you
know like a lot for an entrepreneur but
also by this time I had been sitting on
advisory boards have gotten friendly
with a couple of VCS who were bringing
me into their companies and realizing I
was seeing patterns repeat time and
again from startup to started and I was
just kind of curious that why wasn't
this pattern common wisdom that is we've
been doing venture
in 1999 you know limited partnerships
were about twenty thirty years old in
Silicon Valley venture capitalists have
been doing this for even longer or let's
say forty years as a business why wasn't
the things I were observing common
wisdom and when I started asking my VC
friends I started finding out that there
were VCS with globine guts who could
kind of predict well they're kind of in
this state and here's the odds of this
happening but none of that wisdom had
been pantsed on to entrepreneurship and
so I'm just trying to give you the
rationale of what my thinking was for
coming up with something called the
customer development process and if you
really want details out because I always
forget to say this at the end if at the
end of this lecture
any of this is of interest on Amazon you
could find what really was my class text
which is an excuse of why there's all
kinds of typos and a crummy cover well
the four steps to the Epiphany which
will take you through some
anal-retentive detail about the
methodology probably more than you'll
ever want to know but what really
happened since I've written the text
when I teach it the version of it here
at Stanford in the engineering school I
also teach the same class actually
specifically for development class at
the hospice in school in Berkeley and
then adjoint MBA clients with Columbia
on this early-stage methodology one of
the students in my Berkeley class was an
ex VP of engineering of mine from a
company about ten or fifteen years ago
and he had a very young and eager
co-founder of his new company and the
only way I was going to get involved
with their new company was if they would
sit through my class and lo and behold
not only did they get it but this young
and eager co-founder actually became
somebody who got it better than I did
and went on to take the company using
the customer development methodology
from zero to a million bucks a month
within eighteen months and that's Eric
Ries who will be
part of this presentation I wrote them
into coming because I told them you'll
get sick of listening to me from so Eric
will give you some examples of what it
looked like from the other side is
actually as a practitioner of the
process having nothing but this book
that was looked like it was printed on
tree bark and with that let me go
through where we've taken customer
development today so the goals of this
presentation was to give you some
thoughts about a new way to look at
startups introduced the customer
development and also the Lean Startup
model to you and translate this
knowledge into hopefully a better
company however you are thinking about
or doing a start-up okay well I've never
had anywhere a hundred percent photo
available market I mean this is very
funny okay good all right good you're
the right audience this is not the real
estate glass so let me just repeat some
of the obvious because every good
presenter repeats the obvious to make
you think they're geniuses so they would
just repeat what's going on outside the
building so the economy as one knows
before if you were entrepreneurs up to
literally the spigot shut off six months
ago cash was pretty available here in
the valley
you could get follow-on financing you
did not have to sell your children
before and nowadays we know that debt
markets are tight more importantly for
not only you guys as entrepreneurs but
more importantly for your investors
they're looking at a blank wall when
they used to see liquidity the IPL
market disappeared a year or two ago but
even now the M&A market is gone so
people are doing investing have no idea
how your company is going to get liquid
so they're uttering words never heard
before in the valley about early-stage
companies you know what the word is
profitability Wade said it's a foreign
concept for early-stage ventures and
therefore VCS are depressed now they're
also depressed because a good number of
them were taking monies from pension
funds
College endowments and because of the
drop in the endowments the amount of
money that those funds could put into VC
funds they're actually missing capital
costs the Carver's writing off a good
bunch of VC funds so venture fund
returns have been declined declining for
a decade but now there really is no end
in sight and the state of startups were
historically you built companies with a
high burn rate because you were swinging
for the fences no not everybody was like
this but that was a canonical model if I
told you hey we're gonna swing for the
fences there's gonna you were building
something we're gonna sell or IPO at a
couple hundred million bucks
we're gonna hire a full management team
by that I mean okay we started where's
our VP of Sales VP of Marketing CEO and
CFO what do you mean you don't have them
you're failing and we're going to assume
that this is an execution problem all
right I got a great idea by the way I
was funded from insert name of great VC
here therefore my ideas been blessed and
the only problem between me and
liquidity is execution I need to build
up my build up my company build out my
management team and execute everything
will be great
implicit in that is that I understand
who my customer and market is that was
implicit of course all I have to do is
execute I'm right I assume the features
I need to build are known I know who
those customers are these are the
features I need and all I have to do is
execute my observation is that startups
traditional startups are fighting
yesterday's war this is a
going-out-of-business strategy if any of
you are sitting here going why yes
that's exactly what we're doing
don't don't admit it to anybody sitting
next to you just start you're the ones
looking at their feet going oh maybe the
real estate seminar would be better
because I'm doing this um I will predict
you're out of business except for maybe
some corner cases this is the
traditional model of how to build a
startup and he used to get credit for
the zoo when are you hiring your
salespeople marketing people good you're
going to do a launch great we're
executing